it's about the right collaborators
walking into the room together isn't it
it is like opera it's a collaborative
art form
all these many talented craftsmen i say
talented because
every profession you have to know what
you're doing you have to prepare
you have to get there but all these
people that come together the chemistry
has to work and
how do you make the chemistry work well
i'm not going to say it's a marriage or
a family
but for the moments that you're together
it's a marriage and a family
right for those moments you're only
together for moments
but tolerance give a little
all of that kind of stuff goes into
movie making
and when it comes together the final
thing is
if they don't like it you know move on
in 1977 i hate to jump around but in 77
when william friedkin says i want the
guy that did the rocky movie
to conduct the academy award show i
didn't have a clue
about how to do that show i had to go to
henry mancini
johnny williams alma bernstein the
people who had previously conducted that
[Music]
show
[Music]
this whole thing it's a tv show it began
in the 50s there's a format for the show
music i'm talking about the music i can
only speak about music when they say the
winner is
you play the theme from the show that
just won
and they've been doing this since the
50s i began in the
70s 77 was the first time and i did it
number of times up until whatever the
last time i did it
a lot of years so the melody comes in
and you have to prepare for each of the
five nominees
in each category costume design five
movies
five themes you put them on the paper
for the musicians to go the winner is
and they play the correct one
but i'm talking about the music over the
years
you can't find a theme for the movie
the closer you get to this current
period you go it now the movie is from
i can't imagine movies because i can't
remember
but there's a lot of movies with no
theme there's sound design
there's cans rattling there's
things that happen that go whoosh
and they say well the winner is and you
go whoosh why because that's the only
thing they played in the movie
so that concept of playing the winner
has evolved
or devolved into what do we do
what do we play when they win we can't
find a melody
in many of the scores